now on when scorpions attack each other
both of these scorpions have a needle
sharp stinger filled with venom both are
fighting to the death both want to make
a meal of the other one which is why
they're attacking each other with such
ferocity even though it looks like a
combination wrestling match
tango competition and advanced yoga
class look at this amazing sight one
scorpion finds the tiniest chink and the
other's armor and administers the fatal
sting the vanquished scorpion falls prey
to the lethal neurotoxin it's a goner
all this hullabaloo attracts a third
party a shrew who is all aquiver with
the thought of a scorpion dinner yes
shrews eat scorpions if the Scorpions
don't kill them first the Scorpion is
cannibalizing its victim but it's
incapable of consuming solid food so
what does it do ah well it excretes
enzymes of course to turn the victim
into scorpion soup
mmm yummy the Shrew is on the prowl now
you're probably expecting the Shrew to
go after the easy pickins the dead
scorpion but no the Shrew may look cute
and cuddly in a hyper weird kind of way
but he's nasty enough to cause the live
scorpion to abandon his booty and hide
itself
the shrew poo-poos the stiff he wants a
piece of that live scorpion which is why
this segment is now called when shrews
attack scorpions the Scorpions venom
could easily kill the true but the shrew
has the lightning reflexes of the young
Muhammad Ali he floats like a butterfly
so the Scorpion can't sting like a bee
the shrew needs to eat half its body
weight every day so it's ready to attack
its hungry the shrew Bob's and weaves
and pokes and prods and faints and
Bluffs and then finally it's over it's
all over one lightning bite and the
Shrew will now enjoy the spoils of
victory no rematch no huge gold belt no
job as a casino greeter the spoils of
this victory are eating your opponent at
least boxing hasn't resorted to this
yeah